great to see you both great to see you
too Lisa and now Lisa you you've retired
from the adult industry again is that
rad this is your now you you had your
Michael Jordan return right you're 45
era yes number and now you're retired
again but this time for real for real
yes I've realized something guys I am
just not enough anymore how do you have
some I have no value to the adult
business no none why you know unless I'm
producing my own content which is really
a thankless battle financially when you
could be using content you already own
and using it on multiple platforms and
making a return by recycling yeah when I
work for someone else there's a constant
battle of what I don't want to do what
type of scenes I don't want to do what I
don't want in the script it's a constant
battle then the guys kind of are freaked
out by me cuz I don't want to be choked
and spit on so they're like well what am
I supposed to do with you and they they
really make me feel like I'm not enough
and then on the fan end you know the fan
entitlement now is so extremely
different they all I could swear here
absolutely
okay these girls are now doing this
thing called [ __ ] a fancy [ __ ] a fan so
these girls are running these raffles
and you know I want to specifically but
I know that people are gonna dislike me
but then again nobody likes me anyway I
see so they're running these raffles
where they have guys sign up like 100
bucks you enter this raffle these girls
are cash grabbing a hundred 150 grand
off of these raffles and then they're
picking a friend and doing this scene
with the friend it's like one of those
old radio contest looks like yeah color
number seven gets concert tickets but
that was my buddy fan Fox yes yeah sure
so you know and then also the
prostitution thing and then also like I
will say this I tried to now what I did
was my goal was really to pay back
everything that I lost in court and it
was you know eighty percent of my
savings was lost in about 16 months in a
court battle it was there were multiple
court battles going on there was a
production there was a copyright there
was a stalking there was a death threats
there was harassment it's a bunch
people bound together as a court illegal
Cornucopia know what I ended up walking
it all off and losing and turning away
from all of it because in the one case
this was before internet bullying was
really a thing this was early 2015
you know the judge that I got at that
time really didn't understand the
situation and so when we lost that day
my lawyer says to me well you know we
didn't really lose we can appeal and I
said just do the math for me tell me
what today cost me because I'm not a
gambler so that's like me saying I'm
gonna roll the dice again he's like will
today cost you about $250,000 and how
did it cost you that much him I had to
pay her legal fees the court system in
California pushes you through six or
seven different dates you're paying
lawyers to show why did you have to pay
her legal fees because she put a slap
action on me and at the time the slap
action was used as a blanket to defend
the fact that she could say anything
about me and and it just so happened I
faced a judge that said why do I believe
you know that I should get any privacy
because what I chose to do for a living
was a slap action it's kind of a
silencer in the sense that someone can
do or say anything they want the first
slap action ever was that really was big
was Jerry Falwell right and Larry Flynt
yes yes you remember that case Larry
Flynt won that case and they became
really good friends which was really
bizarre they became good friends Larry
Flynt got to know I think also Jimmy
Carter's sister I think was not Rosalynn
wipe I think his sister or sister-in-law
he had a lot of them became friendly
Larry Flynt so in the short of it this
next run-in was about me saying okay you
need to get this money back how are you
gonna do it you're gonna work
aggressively for 18 months this is what
you're gonna do okay camming even was a
nightmare you don't you're in a room
with thousands of dudes that are like do
this do this can we meet up after why
can't I meet you we you a sex everybody
why you boats you have sex me and the
constant like I felt like a teacher in a
classroom with a bunch of really
disheartened and they're yelling at you
the whole time you like show me your
feet show me this like you could little
it's like you're a monkey watch yeah and
and it was so intense that afterwards I
would feel like I don't drink really
yeah but I would picture that like oh
this is when people have a stiff drink
like the way it was the money worth it
the money is great but at this point I
can't operate any more just for money
and it was the mental toll and also the
fact that like dudes are so
lame now they're so needy and entitled
yes are you going to kamek thinking I
just have fun in masturbate on the
internet for an hour right awesome and
people be like oh my god she's sitting
there masturbating in front of me this
is worthwhile and you don't realize that
the whole thing is gonna not be oh I'm
just here for the show that you're
putting on it's gonna be no you're here
to do exactly what I tell you and to be
yelled at because I don't want to hook
up with them and why cuz you're not a
prostitute every other guy is like why
don't you do [ __ ] fans I just was like
and there was one night I got a little
bit in trouble with the company because
my rule of thumb was I wouldn't start
stripping until the guys would shut up
right thank you you look hot or let's
see your panties come off like hello
people and they would just keep talking
and finally at the halfway point you
know she's messaging me she's like where
are you gonna get naked I'm like yo
these guys just want me to answer their
stupid questions I think I should be
let's sit here dressed yeah and answer
their questions they doing a Q&A I
haven't got naked
I'm just not enough for what the demands
are out there one more Jim and Sam catch
up with full episodes and interviews
from celebrity guests anytime on demand
using the Sirius XM attic